[Musique]
la chine influente dans l'enseignement
supérieur français
c'est la conclusion d'un rapport
sénatorial
exemple concret le pays mettraient la
pression sur des chercheurs chinois et
même français qui traitent de sujets qui
lui déplaisent dans les portes et
accueille
47 mille cinq cents étudiants chinois
étudient en france le rapport démontre
qu'ils sont souvent soumis à une
pression de leurs communautés voire même
directement suspecté de trop de
s'imprégner du modèle démocratique
si le sondage choc du jour pour la
première fois le polémiste eric zemmour
serait qualifié au second tour de la
présidentielle zemmour pour second tour
l'impensable s'est traduit dans les
sondages ombre ou plutôt dans un sondage
celui de challenges harris interactive
et maniema grand est stable mais
derrière ça bouge je suis absolument
dégoûté jusqu'à la nausée de la montée
d'un personnage dans la vie politique
française tout le monde fait comme si
c'était naturel tout le monde fait comme
si c'était normal que quelqu'un vienne
sur toutes les chaînes expliqué que le
maréchal pétain était l'ami des juifs
pendant la guerre je me dis qu'il ya
quand même quelques difficultés à le
voir monter dans les sondages
je me dis que on va enfin ouvrir les
yeux je me dis que ça n'est pas possible
c'est un temps que je vous fais de la
politique et ja
produits sondagier et des produits
électoraux en politique et produits
électoraux ceux pour qui on vote à la
fin c'est ceux qui ont la crédibilité
vous êtes une bulle sondagière comme
certains le disent et ce qu'encore une
fois la bulle zemmour va éclater dans
les prochains mois il ya beaucoup de
gens qui aimeraient bien il fait le show
l'outrance bon vraiment franchement la
présidentielle est parti là dessus sur
le terrain de la présidentielle il ya
avant tout les sondeurs et les
journalistes je pense que les français
sont pas encore rentrés sur le terrain
de la présidentielle une partie des
français s'intéressent à la
présidentielle et les électeurs de la
droite et du centre nous envoie un
message entendez vous rassemblez vous le
plus vite possible raciste négationniste
condamné par la justice de notre pays
pour des faits d' incitation à la haine
raciale qu'est ce que vous voulez de
plus j'espère que l'on va ouvrir les
yeux le garde des sceaux a de la haine
envers ceux qui disent les choses telles
qu'elles sont on n'est pas là pour faire
peur on est là pour résoudre les
problèmes et or ce gouvernement en place
depuis déjà trop de temps ainsi que ses
prédécesseurs n'ont pas à régler les
problèmes des français notamment en ce
qui concerne effectivement descendu
à l'agression qu'ils étaient sortants
simple est-ce que selon vous eric
zemmour est un raciste et un
négationniste toute façon il est
d'extrême droite il est négationniste il
est raciste il est
dit les révisionnistes donc il est
raciste et révisionniste bien sûr jauger
bout de soutien j'ai eu pendant l'été
brigitte bardot qui m'a soutenu j'ai
jean frédéric poisson qui maquille aussi
se rallie à ma candidature éventuelle
donc moi je prends tous les soutiens
fenêtre pas raisonnable parce que vous
êtes un homme politique important vous
êtes vice président du rassemblement
national et vous dînez
lapsus
révélateur vous êtes vice président des
républicains et et vous employer des
mots dans le langage politique qui ne
sont pas adaptés il est vous parle
utilisés par les politiques il est
utilisé par eric zemmour s'est même dit
qu'on est carrément gaza en tout cas ce
n est pas dagan sur le faire ça ça pour
moi ça c'est un argument de campagne
mais pas parler de génocide j'ai bien
parlé d'un processus qui consiste à
injecter de certains quartiers des
personnes qui n'appartiennent pas au
bloc le monde reproche souvent de trop
parler de zemmour je reçois pas mal de
messages à ce sujet je rappelle que ce
19h30 médias celle actu du jour vu par
les médias difficile donc de faire
l'impasse si emmanuel macron et candidat
à la présidence de la république je le
soutiendrai sans la moindre ambiguïté
merci beaucoup à hidalgo d'avoir été
notre candidat c'est à vous notre
candidat